this story of Magdalene and Christ using
this energy of sacred Union and Sexual
Energy to you take the polarities of
masculine and feminine bring them into
Union for the manifestation of this
energetic body I think it's interesting
how we've suppressed the story in
spirituality that sexuality is a big
part of that and this is where we get
into Tantra talking about the power of
sex as a tool in Tantra and that Aeros
gamos being like sacred Union in from
the Greeks but then when we look at the
myuna rituals and Tantra or tantric
Tibetan Buddhism and we start to really
learn that maybe God wasn't just a man
in the clouds you know God has feminine
and masculine aspects and it's actually
the union of that I think we're Oneness
who is remembering tuness people teach
that we're tuness remembering Oneness
but we're already Oneness learning how
to play tuness